I'm gonna ask you the question that is
most on my mind which is here in LA you
know things are starting to they're
trying to relax things a little bit are
you able to to get outside the house cuz
that's the only way to stay sane if you
can be responsible but still get outside
somehow I can't I I live in a
neighborhood that is very conducive to
walking and that sort of thing there's a
lot of face mask shaming going on you
know if people aren't wearing face masks
then yeah yeah real dirty looks and the
dirty looks are even dirtier when
they're from behind the mask because
it's just eyes it's more intense but I
actually support that I support shaming
non face masks where because someone
could like sneeze and kill your family
so like let's just all be responsible
here it's one thing if someone doesn't
want to practice social distancing
themselves but there are people that
will invade your space yes they're
willfully getting into someone else's
grill which seems weird yeah I'm kind of
a leave me alone guy in and on and on a
normal day and at this point it's like
yeah everybody just better back off you
know yeah I'm saying close ya know so I
think I'm too close right now yeah
you're freaking me out okay you guys
close as I wanted and this is eight this
is HD baby you can feel the anxiety you
know even when you're just you know
walking around socially distance if you
see other people you can sense there's a
lot of tension out there yeah and I
think I just think everybody everybody's
sort of baseline anxiety is a little bit
higher right now I was out for a walk
and there was a guy in this in this sort
of grassy area doing yoga like it looked
like he probably did yoga videos for
people like he's an incredible physique
he just had a little tiny
and was doing these poses and it was it
was like kind of amazing then he starts
he kind of takes this meditation pose
and really sinks into this deep state of
meditation or relaxation or something
and I was like pant this is awesome I
wish I could kind of like have that much
peace during this crazy time we wound up
walking back to our car in this parking
lot
and there's no cars in this parking lot
except for ours and then his and he he
walks past us goes to his car as we're
sitting there another car comes into
this empty parking lot and pulls in
right next to him which during this time
is kind of a weird move right like
there's plenty of other places to park
yeah the parking space is pulling
anywhere so this guy pulls in right next
to hit the Zen masters car he sees this
and he goes white is at peace as I
thought I feel better when I find it
that the Zen guy's totally lose it
completely is it my wife and I just
burst out laughing and we started don't
drive home we were going to cut now my
daughter who is two and a half years old
internalized that it she says it all the
time so it'll be like come on we got to
put your shoes that's what she took away
from the Zen master yeah exactly